Reggie was somebody who was quite deep
emotionally deep
his fault was he was a drinker was on
gen all the time and taking speed
Ronnie was a different kind of fish
altogether deep down with his tormented
demonized man
when he didn't take his medication
he was off the Spectrum he was off the
roof
and you never knew what was going to
happen and I remember Ronnie saying to
me one day
he said Chrissy said if anybody ever
touch regime
he said I've put a dynamite jacket on
whatever detonate his ready he said I'd
lie em and I'd walk amongst that walkway
amongst them and our blood a lot and he
meant it
meant it he would be prepared to die for
his brother and it was reversed the same
thing